every nation has not only the right but
the absolute duty to protect its borders
and its citizens the nation without
borders is a nation not at all without
borders we have the reign of chaos crime
cartels and believe it or not coyotes I
will not surrender this nation to the
whims of criminal organizations who prey
on the vulnerable who hurt women and
children and who spread human misery and
suffering human trafficking and massive
drug in flow must also be stopped it's
at a tremendous level what we're doing
and the incredible job being done by
border security ice Border Patrol local
police and the military the military has
been incredible and we stopping them to
process you wouldn't believe how tough
but we're stopping them in record
numbers at this moment there is a debate
over funding border security in the wall
also called so that I give them a little
bit of an out steel slats we don't use
the word wall necessarily but it has to
be something special
to do the job steel slots I've made my
position very clear any measure that
funds the government must include border
security Hesston